so it's fun to watch joe biden who's now
been completely hijacked by the radical
left to the extent that he is now giving
the go-ahead to the most radical members
of the radical left now remember we've
been told that joe biden is moderate and
the democratic party is a party of
moderates we were told that the only
people who are into norm breaking are
the people on the right right donald
trump was a guy who's going to violate
norms he's all about norm violation
shattering the norms and there are some
people who celebrated that okay joe
biden shattered norms barack obama
shattered norms the dirty little secret
of american politics is that when you
grant all power to the executive branch
pretty quickly norms begin to be
shattered and when the american people
are
willing to run roughshod over norms to
get to utopia those norms end up being
trampled
joe biden was captain norms when he was
in the senate right he was he was the
guy who was working across the aisle and
and he was the one who was upholding the
filibuster knowledge now he's talking
about shattering the filibuster now he
is talking about how the democrats need
to ram through every deal without any
bipartisan support hey this reared its
ugliest head yesterday when protesters
followed kristen cinema who's the
senator from arizona who again is sort
of the democratic john mccain in all of
this protesters follow kirsten cinema
into the bathroom here's a little bit of
view of what that looked like
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we we're not going forward we need
solutions to build that better plan need
has the solutions that we need we
knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need seven million citizenship for seven
million we need the
benefit right now
um i'm just going to uh point out here
that i it is my personal belief that
everyone ought to be able to poop in
peace this is my personal belief i want
to live in an america where we can all
take a dump in privacy and peace if
that's too much for you well you can
find plenty of left-wing programs that
will tell you differently i was told
that women's spaces were sacred spaces
apparently not if you're going to vote
in favor of a bipartisan infrastructure
act but not in favor of a 3.5 trillion
dollar spending act now the part of this
that's amazing is how much kind of soft
support the protesters receive for
following christian sentiment to a
bathroom
imagine feeding republicans following
christian sentiment to a bathroom there
had been talk of rape culture there have
been talk of the fears that women have
to experience when they go into a public
restroom of of assault that these are
private spaces
but when it's left as following kirsten
sent him into a bathroom very different
story so the protesters follow kirsten
cinema into the bathroom and joe biden
is asked about this yesterday now you
would imagine that joe biden remember he
ran for office on the basis of he was a
moral person who was going to restore
the soul the nation no more norms
violations back to norms back to
conciliatory language back to unity well
joe biden was asked about people
following christian cinema into the
bathroom and uh here were his rather
tepid remarks
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so it's it's part of the
process
it's part of the process it's part of
the process it's inappropriate but it
happens to everybody and it's part of
the process does it though
does it really happen to everybody and
is the response from the president of
the united states the same way
it's amazing what sort of norm violation
is considered totally
okay or unworthy of further comment by
the democratic establishment what sort
of norm violation is deeply worthy of
comment by the establishment if tucker
carlson does a segment about military
uniforms for pregnant pilots that is
worthy of the worst sort of ire from the
federal government but if a sitting
united states senator is followed into
the bathroom by protesters
then that is worthy of a shrug a little
bit of a you know it happens whatever
again it it is incredible the sort of
treatment to which the the democrats
believe that people ought to be
subjected so long as they are on the
wrong side of a political issue she's a
democratic senator this is not even
republican but this goes all the way
back to the trump administration
right this goes back to the notion that
if you have the wrong sorts of views
then you ought to be browbeaten if you
have the wrong sorts of views then you
ought to be run out of restaurants like
sarah huckabee sanders
if you have the wrong sort of views you
ought to be intimidated in life like
this kristen cinema will be fine she's a
sitting united states senator
but the problem is that this sort of
attitude bleeds down to pretty much
everything if you have the wrong views
in american life you can be bullied out
of your job you can be ostracized from
your social community you can be treated
like garbage and a lot of people will
just kind of shrug and go well you know
you deserved it you had the wrong sorts
of views
okay that's really really ugly stuff and
unfortunately you saw a lot of blue
checks on twitter yesterday who are
basically talking up that sort of
position
and most famously jezebel which is of
course a radical left side
they put up a piece titled absolutely
holy christian cinema outside of her
bathroom stall
the senator is holding all of us back
and some of her most vulnerable
constituents are rightfully sick of it
this is by a columnist named ashley
reese quote the effectiveness of certain
kinds of protests will always be up for
debate so naturally a group of activists
pursuing senator kirsten cinema around
arizona state university campus over the
weekend and controversially somehow
briefly following cinema into a public
restroom to note that their family
members were deported is bound to prompt
some pearl clutching
on sunday social justice organization
living united for change in arizona
uploaded a video of activists asking
cinema to defend her opposition to
president biden's buildback better act
democrats at large support the bill but
mansion and cinema do not
it's no wonder her constituents who
don't understand what the f she's doing
any better than the rest of us are
piping mad mad enough to pester her
after she finished teaching a class at
asu
lucha's video shows a group of activists
waiting outside cinema's classroom when
she emerges they ask if they could talk
to her briefly about the importance of
buildback better she's actually i'm
heading out and then she went down to a
bathroom we knocked on doors for you to
get elected said an activist named
blanca and just how he got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us cue
the sounds of toilets flushing
apparently the only thing not right was
following cinema into the bathroom
just wow just terrible just terrible
and how could you know
how could people be upset that this
would happen again so jen saki yesterday
she tried to walk this back because even
some of the members of the body
administration are like this is a little
much so here's john saki trying to walk
this back a little bit
what happened this weekend was that her
classroom her students uh and and the
safe and intellectually stimulating
environment she's worked to create
during the years she's of teaching at at
asu was breached that's inappropriate
and unacceptable and i think the context
of what happened here is important
despite the fact that of course we stand
for the president stands for the
fundamental right of people to protest
to object to criticize
as they often do outside of the gates of
the white house
okay so
the question for the democratic party is
going to be whether they actually stand
up to this sort of stuff because
remember we can pretend that this is
sort of an isolated incident but
main large parts of the democratic party
last year we're fine with people burning
down entire cities
and they we spent an entire year
pretending the riots weren't happening
in america's major cities so that the
media and democrats could pretend that
the protests over george floyd's death
had not in fact morphed into riots
meanwhile kamala harris the current
president of the united states vice
president i make the mistake the same
mistake job makes
vice president kamala harris is tweeting
out bail funds for for people who are
burning things down in places like
minnesota
so when we talk about norm violation and
rule breaking and where we go from here
we have to understand that if the nor in
many cases the norm violation is
happening inside the house and it has
now hijacked many of the people who used
to be considered moderates including joe
biden
and that is very scary for the future of
the country it matters an awful lot more
than how much money we spend in the next
month or so and that matters an awful
lot but i'll tell you what matters even
more is the fact that we have now
reached the point in american politics
where huge swaths of the american people
are just like you can do whatever you
want to do so long as it helps you
achieve the purpose you want to achieve
that is a recipe for the country falling
apart
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment